in this lesson you learned about key
metrics and how to go about measuring
them ultimately your product and
business goals won't form what you
measure and don't forget that you can
use the heart framework to help you
refine your thinking and figure out next
steps you heard from Aaron Harris about
to vanity metrics and about actionable
metrics you also learn from other
startups about what they measure you
have a great foundation for using these
metrics to improve your product now it's
time for you to go out and do that we
hope you enjoyed this course and are
eager to learn more than what we covered
here continue to dream up amazing ideas
and always push yourself to bring
delightful and useful products to the
world